shrimps
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
shrimps what the hell do you think
you're doing you silly little kid around
are you perhaps lost on your way to one
of Berlin's many world famous chocolate
shops or museums no I was just thinking
what if we turn this little concert into
a little river
of course of course challenging me to a
whiff off the Americans who are
obstacles with your weapons whip off
yeah whip off it's a riff-off whiff off
Riff Off you said with of acid refer
okay
and I wouldn't love to be a part of the
web of but unfortunately the acapella
bylaws clearly stayed a quorum of
acapella pears must be present for a
whiff up to be legally binding so it's
sad yeah it's actually not sad nine it's
not sad at all because if you were to
reread page 45 paragraph seven it
clearly states in the case of an
international rip-off within 100
kilometers of affordable River the
Quorum can be waved
all right then
what is the stakes if I win
I get to say whatever I want to all of
your followers on your live stream
okay and uh when I win
if you win I will
go back to America
today
all right son
I've met you all terms but
we are on my hometown so the scene is
Germany you will sing German songs and I
will sing on never concerned
you're about to go down
here I am
Rock You Like a Hurricane
brings all the boys to the yard and
they're like it's better than yours damn
right it's better than yours I can teach
you I know you want it
[Music]
[Applause]
do what I wanna do
[Applause]
you're supposed to be helping me
[Applause]
you're supposed to be doing my songs
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
those were your rules
money and fame and he peed in the bucket
and yet his blood runs Maple sorry buddy
where's the live stream hey what's up
I'm Buffalo rolling check out my new
song written by my girl Heidi Miller
you are so lucky you have an X who was
looking after you your career almost
ending today
I know about the thing
look like I said before I went into I
swear
I'm talking
about the DSM then your thing sounds
good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]